and some NBA LIVE just cut why not you
know do your thing anyway here you go so
Star Wars Battlefront - folks now this
is awesome because essentially abatement
I don't get their average trooper
they're also able to pop that combat
shield try to push into area so you can
see those guys pushers or defenders in
some areas but looks like we got one of
our vulture droids right now not sure
who's flying this guy but these guys are
great at air-to-air trying to take out
those other ships that might be coming
in the who and one star fighter
otherwise you're there to provide some
great ground support like we're seeing
here trying to get some strafing runs in
on those cones oh come on man miss
that's our you just you just rush it
wrong there although we see here a
little clip of the V wing doing that up
man he's just mowing some some droids
down there
yeah just absolutely shredding you're
going to see this happen quite a bit
especially in this phase because there's
a lot of open fields here right and you
just come through for some great
straight great bombing runs really and
eliminate as many people as possible
cannon also you to the presence of an
air vehicle out there players will fear
the skies and they will you know look
for cover in this map where it's really
difficult to find cover to begin with in
this phase
absolutely and you can see right now
that there is an 80 tank sitting around
on the battlefield he has probably taken
out those phone troopers but this is yes
absolutely it's something that is oh
that's painful they saw flak for
something that a lot of players will be
able to jump right into there your
frontline flanker attacker
I could destroy people so I just charged
into the room and just absolutely
shredded everyone it was so fun to play
with here we also seen some great dogs
right here between the clones and the
separatist this is certainly what a lot
of folks love in Star Wars and just
really in any game that dice makes right
they just always do a good job of the
air coming he's really trying to track
him down this fire a lot slower but you
can get some great shots with it and
then there's also this nice compact SMG
style you know laughter that really
shreds through people in close range
we want to give me a mentor what variety
to snub around you know yeah
also some adj oxygen hero we didn't get
to see this one before final Anto adding
some 80 artis yes so these are great for
kicking out those a 80 so these guys a
little quick they have an ion charge
ability that way we'll be able to do a
little bit more extra damage against the
tanks as they see it so you can imagine
like three or four days on the
battlefield really rushing around points
like look at this you just can pick up
someone out what can you what can you do
with this you get like you can't run
summer over if you want
oh I was actually gonna say could I get
shot off of it if I'm on top of it
because my body is exposed yeah yeah
that was that question was answered you
know almost immediately yeah almost
immediately oh man so mr. moose elk here
you know what for this guy to be on a
tear a little bit later as well and also
I did want to highlight we had an
officer as a matter of fact right in
front of okay one of my favorite classes
what is it about the officer that makes
it so unique I mean my my twitch bill is
art where they used to be I'm slower
nowadays but I'm able to really puff up
my class I buff up my teammates try to
let them get some extra health let them
push me with ones faster and Oh what
happened Wiley probably some good dog
fight it going in there okay so right
and when a rider what's great about some
of these starfighters is these are
access through our new battle point
systems so instead of finding a pickup
token on the on the map like we used to
in the last game you're now able to
defend
they she have time for this air combat
is some vehicle gameplay but once we get
inside it's gonna be a different story
that's right
things are definitely beat up and what
is this happening right this is a
lockout on shake them out yep alright
they better enjoy their air combat here
because that's not going to be happening
for much longer
oh man trying him oh nice job you know
that true sniper character you set up
some tripmines behind yourself make sure
nobody can flank you but really they
provide such a tight cover fire your
shoes downrange and it's especially
hopeless in this area because it is such
a big open area so that specialist
really shines more bombing runs here and
just absolutely tearing them up at
meseta and we hope push you know when
those heavies are trying to drive
towards a point
you got your officer behind you giving
you some extra help making sure that
you're not you're still able to complete
that push or on the opposite side if
you're one of the joys you really need
to lock
the officers have access to a turret
that they can place on the ground and
you know give me a little bit more fire
support for that area trying to see
massive G here's a you know he's really
focused on the bombing runs right he's
not trying to go into combat with Musa
who's up there there's a darkness 49
just shredding everyone up here maybe I
don't get a couple just went to the
beach mode yeah this is happening oh yes
so tell us about the siege mode well
this is houses play out in siege mode
you have two guys near the battle point
system those guys great at pushes points
again they have high health a lot of
rapid fire oh here we go oh there it is
and this big explosion indicates phase 1
is over now we start phase 2 and this is
when the action really begins to pick up
here